fantastic and we're all we've all got
more money to spend while families rely
on food banks and wire more people and
more children in poverty than ever
before I think you are some absolutely
key question I'm not saying everything
is perfect I'm saying we have not
finished the work that's why I'm so keen
to do another five years of continuing
to get the country back to work to build
a strong economy to pay down our debts
and to hand on a really good country to
our children that's what this is all
about I'm not saying we fixed it it
takes a long time to fix the mess that I
was left to clear up but what I would
say is we're halfway through a building
job now you can keep the team that are
building the stronger economy or you can
go back to the team frankly that well
the ones that designed the building that
fell down in the first place and I think
that'd be a terrible mistake you want to
come in and I'll come to you and then
move on yes you talk about the sort of
country you want to hand on to our
children I don't want to handle a
country to my child where there are a
million using food banks where people
have been hit by really punitive benefit
sanctions people have died out you know
from from the bedroom tax we've got
cases where people have a disabled yeah
we've had the disabled daughter died and
then receive a demand for bedroom tax
for the spare room that disabled
daughter has left behind that is not a
country I want to hand onto my child
quick question let me say I don't want
anyone to have to rely on a food bank in
our country it's important that they're
there but I don't anyone to have to rely
on them the most importantly prime
minister in nature absolutely the most
important thing we can do is to get more
people into work that's the best route
out of poverty that two million more
jobs is more than the rest of Europe put
together but have we finished the job
someone said 0 Escalante one in 50 jobs
is a zero-hours contract two-thirds of
the jobs we created our full-time jobs
now if you're saying the job isn't
finished I absolutely agree and that is
why I'm so passionate about completing
the job and Madam you asked what country
do you want to pass on to our children I
don't want us to go on borrowing year
after year racking up debts that we then
asked our children to pay because we
didn't have the courage to pay them off
ourselves